hey guys i'm new CN welcome to in two
minutes now the reviews for Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain went live on
Sunday and it got the perfect 10 from
our own piece of brown so then I of
course fell into a deep dark Wikipedia
whole trying to find out more about the
game and I came up with these five
awesome things that you might not know
about the phantom pain and just a role
on the same page here there's no story
spoilers cuz I'm not a jerk despite
Konami zhit mped to a rays game director
Hideo Kojima out of their lives like an
ex-boyfriend his name still crops up in
the main game a lot like you will play
this game and be under no doubt the
kajima made it yes the weird plot twists
are there and the reason that quiet is
running around half naked is pretty much
the most Kojima thing ever but the words
a Hideo Kojima game are plastered all
over that thing there at the beginning
of the game and at the end of pretty
much every mission because credits roll
while you're in the helicopter on your
way back to mother base so while that
much valued box credit is no longer
there his influence is definitely felt
all over a cool gameplay mechanic next
so while you're wandering around the
plains of Afghanistan and Africa you'll
find locals who you can talk to for
information well only if you've got the
corresponding translator back at mother
base to act as your Babel Fish over the
radio but what about Russian by the way
your brushing is superb well at the
start of the phantom pain snake is
coming out of this nine-year coma and
while his mobility has been unaffected
due to all these massages he's been
having and he has this neat new rocket
powered arm his speech has taken a hit
and he's totally forgotten how to speak
Russian and talking about that rocket
arm it is basically the most awesome
thing in the game it can be upgraded and
used along with your wide arsenal of
guns to switch up how you play for
example you can grab things for distance
stun people using electricity or even
pound the ground sending out a Sona
blast that reveals the locations of
nearby enemies kojima's love of David
Bowie is well-known like when major zero
took a codename Major Tom in Metal Gear
solitary snake eater but the phantom
pain was originally supposed to open
with the song Diamond Dogs from Bowie's
1974 album of the same name Kojima's
team were apparently against the idea
and so the song was changed but big
bosses private military company in the
phantom pain is called diamond dogs and
you can listen to Bowie's hit the man
who sold the world on cassette as you
drive around the game and finally a
quick easter egg as Metal Gear is always
full of those while we're all still
lamenting the cancellation of Kojima
side project silent Hills there is a
reference to it in the phantom pain as
we can see in this video here the active
decoy used to distract some enemies is
none other than horrendous ghost thing
Lisa from PT so there we have it five
things about Metal Gear Solid 5 that
I've definitely worth shouting about and
unlisted and as I said earlier it got
the perfect 10 from us so why don't you
take a look at Peter's review or check
out Danny's list of the top five
weirdest bosses in Metal Gear history
and for more on Metal Gear make sure you
keep your eye on gamespot don't forget
i'm on twitter at Lucy James games and
I'll see you next week
you